When you head under the sea, sometimes
magic happens in unexpected ways. This
surprise cameo in The Little Mermaid has
fans singing with joy. Spoilers ahead!
The live-action remake of "The Little
Mermaid" boasts an impressive cast and
dazzling musical numbers led by Halle Bailey's
acclaimed performance as Ariel. So far,
fans on Twitter have had positive reactions
that align with the early reactions from
critics and moviegoers. They also praise
Melissa McCarthy's lively portrayal of
Ursula the sea witch, as well as
a surprising and delightful cameo.
The original animated classic premiered in 1989
and introduced Ariel as a beloved icon.
Given the importance of the character,
it was only right to include a very special guest
during the second half of the 2023 reimagining.
After Ursula's sinister spell transforms the young
mermaid, Ariel ascends to the surface of the ocean
on her new legs. She reconnects with Prince Eric
and enjoys a colorful day in the royal kingdom
while sampling the many offerings on land. Among
the welcoming locals, one helpful vendor happens
to be none other than Jodi Benson, who voiced
Ariel in the original animated treasure.
Even though Ariel is unable to
speak during this exciting exchange,
Jodi Benson's captivating presence more than
makes up for it. It isn't immediately clear
that Benson is playing the market vendor,
but the sound of the original Ariel's voice
will certainly have the audience's
ears perked up before her big reveal.
"I get recognized a lot as the voice of her."
She holds up a fork and tells Ariel she
may be needing it — Ariel then misuses
the renowned "dinglehopper" by running it
through her hair. In both versions of "The
Little Mermaid," the seagull Scuttle
mistakes the instrument for a comb.
"Just a little twirl here
and a yank there and viola."
As Benson gives her the fitting gift, it
also feels like a passing of the torch
moment between the two actresses that
crowns Bailey as the new Ariel. This
loving inclusion pays tribute to Benson's
heartfelt depiction while also celebrating
Bailey's groundbreaking role. In a story about
combining two worlds, this is a wonderful
interaction that seamlessly threads the two
versions of "The Little Mermaid" together.
The scene in which Halle Bailey's Ariel receives
the dinglehopper was always present in the script,
but the idea of bringing Benson in manifested
a bit later. While discussing her cameo with
Entertainment Weekly, Benson expressed just
how excited she was to return to the world
of "The Little Mermaid" and work with director
Rob Marshall, her friend for over four decades.
"It was just a huge thrill for me when Robbie
reached out. I'm like, 'Of course I'm gonna come!
I don't care what I'm doing. I just can't wait to
get around the set and watch all of you work.'"
For Marshall, it was important to fold
Benson into the film in a way that felt
organic and not "stunt-y." The director
also told the outlet that having the two
Ariels on set was a major win that
brought the cast and crew together.
"The Little Mermaid" continues to
receive praise for its lead performances,
with Halle Bailey consistently singled out for
her take on Ariel. While Bailey is receiving
her fair share of love from Disney fans across
the world, it's Jodi Benson's approval that has
her jumping for joy. Bailey talked about Benson
in a chat with the Los Angeles Times, saying:
"She told me how proud she was of
me and how I'm handling everything,
and encouraged me to just go for it. I appreciate
her for being so warm and welcoming to me because
she's the GOAT, and it was important
to me to get her stamp of approval."